[Music]
can i help you sir
you can help me find maria oh maria's
gone we're completely self-checkout now
please scan your item please scan your
item
i just did please scan your item yeah
right
sir this can't keep happening
you're not putting me in a hall what if
it were our home
grandpa hi grandpa hello sweetheart
how's your daughter's place that she
gave me my grandson's room he's not too
happy about it how do you like your room
kid look i didn't want it to be this way
either i just want my room back
get away from me oh come on
i want to put up with this piece i
demand my room back or else it's
more declaration of war give me
back what is mine face the consequences
okay okay you got your wish
what the
so let me get this straight you want me
to help you and your birthdays help beat
up your grandson and his buddies because
the two of you can't figure out some way
to live in the same
house well when you put it like that i'm
in
this kind of aggression
i didn't know you were a marine it
wasn't
just saying let's do this
do you guys even remember how to play
dodgeball so you don't need your diaper
changed
sure you don't
run for your life why are we doing it
this way when you have peace talks you
need someone neutral to mediate
you gave me a cookie it is true a cookie
was given
i think your grandpa might be a ninja we
gotta end this somehow
[Music]
did you see that
[Music]
you